well we heard that warning from Jeremy
Hunter on the program this morning that
we'll all pay a bit more tax and there
will be what he calls very difficult
decisions on public spending too with
nurses due to go on strike across the
NHS soon and more strikes in the public
sector I can now speak to the general
secretary at the UK's biggest Union
Unison which represents more than a
million public sector workers that is
Christina mcenay and she joins us now
thank you for being on the program this
morning
um Jeremy Hunt said the NHS can find
efficiencies is he right
uh I'm sure that any organization can
still find an element of efficiency
savings but I think it's a bit of a one
of these words that that's a bit of a
red flag to many public sector workers
because it so often means cuts and
that's the worry is that the NHS is
basically on its needs at the moment uh
I've been spending the the past week
going around speaking to our members
across the country you listen people who
are paramedics and nurses and uh theater
staff in hospitals and I can tell you
that I don't think there's much room for
any efficiency savings what they want to
see is more investment in the NHS they
want to see a pay rate that actually
encourages people to join the NHS and
crucially to stay in the NHS
the latest figures that we showed to
Jeremy Hunt on any waiting times show at
records number of people waiting more
than four hours and then I'm waiting
more than 12 hours was up 30 percent
almost 44
000. what kind of impact could spending
restraint have on the NHS could it be
dangerous
of course okay then what we I mean
you've just said to yourself that um
waiting listed at an all-time high we've
got um the biggest highest level of
public dissatisfaction with the NHS
since it started we've got 135
000 vacancies in the NHS and you know
people are waiting in ambulances outside
hospitals from five six seven as long as
10 hours but you basically using
ambulances as another room of the
hospital which is not really an
efficient use of of ambulances and this
will have it's already having an impact
on British people and it will just only
get worse you know when I hear
conversations talk about you know
difficult choices to be made of course
that's true but there's also difficult
choices what difficult things will
happen if we don't make the right
choices if they don't make the right
choices and one of those will be the NHS
is is almost ready to collapse and
excuse me for saying that like a
conspiracy theaters but I've had so many
people say it now is this a partly a
delivery attempt by the government to
run down the NHS in order to turn around
and say we'll have to bring in some
private organizations around it now I
hope that's not and a bit of me thanks
that's not what they're doing but what
they're not doing is taking the right
choices about investing in our public
services and it doesn't make sense
economically either
um because with it we've had what 12
years of near enough austerity or public
sector pay freezers and what's happened
the country hasn't grown the economy
hasn't grown uh you know the Dreadful
experiment that we had was trust where
she tried to just ramp all of that up
just showed what a bad strategy that is
and actually if you invest in the
working people of this country if you
see them as wealth generators and you
actually give them decent paying pay to
be able to generate that wealth then
that makes a difference to the local
economies and that's how you generate
that you get the economy back on the
speed again
I just want to come in because do you
really believe that the government is
deliberately trying to run the NHS down
because I feel like there are some
people in government who might find that
you know a bit offensive
I'm sure and as I said you know I don't
like to get into Hennessy theaters but I
honestly sometimes when I go around and
I see what's happening in some of their
the nhas when I hear stories from people
who are working Unison members who are
working as nurses paramedics uh when I
hear what they have to tell me a bit of
me does think what is going on here How
can any poll session allow this to
happen uh you know to something that is
so valued by the British public so no
I'm not saying for definite that's
what's happening but every now and then
it does enter my mind at that maybe
what's happened I suspect I would
absolutely hope Jeremy Hunt certainly
doesn't think that given his views on
the NHS but I think sometimes to sort of
blame everything on you know external
other world affairs like Ukraine is
wrong because the problems in the NHS
and the social care sector were were
well known long before the Ukraine
crisis happened uh you know it's not
been wages that are pushing up inflation
and some of the decisions are taking
just a couple of months ago by the by
the Tory government have certainly made
things worse and none of the people I
represent in unison who do these
essential Public Services we're
responsible for any of that but they
will now be the ones being told we can't
give you more money because the
countries in such a state well I'm sorry
but politicians have to decide whether
they're going to spend their money
that's what they're paid to do is take
those difficult decisions let's let's
talk about uh money
um because of course there are the pay
negotiations uh going on you know given
the fact that you know as you accept
money is really short in the NHS you
worried that it could lead to dangerous
outcomes
is it really right that the Royal
College of Nursing is asking for a 17
pay rise
well that's what the Royal College and
asking for and you know they've now got
a yes vote in a large number of uh uh
any large parts of the NHS to take
industrial action we're balloting our
members over 300 000 in the NHS who uh
our ballot closes on the 25th of
November and we're asking them to vote
Yes for strike action too so we will
definitely be talking and working with
the Royal College of Nursing we get a
yes vote too there aren't pay
negotiations below and I'm afraid it's
sad to say uh you know ministers are
telling us there's no more money there's
nobody sitting down to discuss this with
us and what I keep seeing is a
straight's not inevitable in the NHS
Australia's not inevitable anywhere a
strength is a symptom of a problem it's
not in itself because of a problem and I
would Arch Jeremy Hunt and other
government ministers to sit down with
the trade unions and actually talk to us
about how we can solve this
the house secretary Steve Barkley
described a 17 pay Rises neither
reasonable nor affordable is that kind
of the kind of level that Unison might
be asking for as well
we're looking for an inflation-proofed
pay award I think it's really important
that staff get something that actually
means they can stay in in work and look
at other families at the same time you
know they offer that that they offer the
award that has been made to NHS workers
in England Wales and Northern Ireland is
a 1400 pounds flat rate now for most
nurses that represents and most nurses
and people in that professional brand if
you like me call them within the NHS but
most of them it represents between four
and four point two percent inflation is
now running well over yeah over 10
expected to be even go as high as 12
that cannot be right that we're
expecting these workers to continue to
do their job a very demanding job and
yet take what is an effort to pick up
and no wonder so many of them and leave
in the sector you know they're going to
take jobs elsewhere you know you look at
what happens in the retail sector uh
Tesco Asda Sainsbury's little all the
have all given their staff at least two
and in some places three p increases
this year now if the government the
government answer to us is always we've
implemented the peer review body report
them through and that's true but what
they could do is reconvene the peer
review worthy to actually say to them
things have changed drastically since
they took their decision to award 1400
pounds and actually asked them to
reconsider and see what would be a fair
offer to give to public sector workers
and indeed NHS workers okay thank you
very much indeed for being on the
program this morning Christina mcino
there of unison
thank you